- [Narrator] In previous
videos we talked about
the dramatic turn around
in the fourth century
in terms of how Christianity
was treated in the Roman Empire.
As you enter into the fourth century
it's persecuted by Diocletian
but then Constantine takes power.
He's sympathetic to the Christians.
He even convinced them in
order to unify the Christians
to have a more unified sense
of what it means to be Christian,
in order to settle things
like the Arian controversy
and he converts himself to Christianity.
And as we exit the fourth century
you have Theodosius who makes Christianity
the official religion of the Roman Empire
and then begins to
persecute other religions.
Now what we're going to do in this video
is continue the narrative
and in particular,
we're going to see how
there's an evolution
between the church in the west
and the church in the east.
In previous videos we already talk about
how the Roman Empire itself has
initially administered
between west and east,
and then that administration
becomes more and more formal.
Theodosius is the last emperor
to truly rule both halves.
They start getting ruled separately
and as you get into the latter
half of the fifth century
the western empire itself
falls to Germanic conquerors.
Now in previous videos we talk about
how the emperors who
rule from Constantinople
consider themselves to
continue the Roman Empire.
They didn't call themselves
the Byzantine Empire
as we now call them.
They call themselves the Roman Empire.
They consider themselves Roman emperors.
The west falls as I just mentioned
into a bunch of Germanic kingdoms.
Justinian is able to
reclaim a lot of the land
formerly lost in the Western Roman Empire.
Now there's some interesting actors
we see emerging on this map
and once again, we're
now in the sixth century.
You have these Germanic tribes,
the Visigothic Kingdoms
here in modern day Spain
and here in modern day
France you have the Franks,
and the word France really is referring to
land of the Franks,
another Germanic tribe.
Now, they are about to factor
much, much more relevantly
and when I say about I'm saying
over the next several hundred years
in this eventual division
culturally and religiously
between east and west.
As I mentioned in previous videos,
the division, yes, it will
center on notions of language.
In the west especially in
the church Latin is used.
In the east in the church Greek is used.
There's spiritual debates
that we will touch on in a few minutes
but there's also a power struggle.
You have the Byzantine emperor
seated in Constantinople.
You have the bishop of Rome
now known as the pope,
really the pope of Rome
who considers themselves more and more
the leader of all of Christianity.
And their argument there is
look, this is the church
that according to tradition
was founded by Peter,
first amongst the apostles.
You have the patriarch of Constantinople
and patriarchs of other
significant centers of Christianity
to say, wait, hold on a second.
Yes, bishop of Rome you are very important
but we consider you to
be first amongst equals.
You don't have jurisdiction
over all of Christendom.
Together we have jurisdiction.
And this was to some degree
the case under Justinian
and it was very clear at this time
that the Byzantine
emperor was very powerful
not just over the temporal realm
really referring to the
day to day material realm,
but also a lot of influence
on the spiritual realm
which was really supposed to be the domain
of the bishops or the
popes or the patriarchs.
This notion of the Pentarchy was codified
in the Justinian law,
this idea that these five
centers of Christianity
really have extra weight and collectively
are really leading Christendom.
Now as I mentioned, things get interesting
as we fast forward about 250 years.
Let's go to the year 800.
One thing you might notice
is that group in yellow,
the Franks have now conquered a lot more
and they're conquering
it under the leadership
of Charlemagne.
At the same time, you
see this green over here,
Islam has dramatically
spread from its founding
in the early seventh
century all the way now
as we're exiting the eighth century
to cover most of the Middle East, Persia,
bordering on modern day
Pakistan, India, North Africa
and even going into modern day Spain.
At the same time especially because
of this Islamic conquest,
the Byzantine Empire and
the Byzantine emperor
is significantly weaker.
You could imagine the pope
in Rome here is saying,
"Well, who's going to protect me
"especially from my political enemies?"
Now Charlemagne considers himself
something of a protector of Christianity.
And Pope Leo III goes
to him for protection
and Charlemagne is able
to actually provide it.
And in exchange or perhaps
in thanks for that,
the pope crowns Charlemagne
as Holy Roman Emperor.
Now what's significant about this
is it really introduces
a fourth actor here
because the title Holy Roman Emperor
was intentionally given to say, look,
now you Charlemagne, you are the heir
to the grandeur of Rome.
You are the heir to the Roman emperors.
Now, you might be saying wait,
isn't that what the Byzantine
emperors thought they were?
Didn't they think this
was the Roman Empire?
And at that time their
emperor was an empress.
It was Empress Irene of Athens.
And so once again, this is
creating further tension.
They're using different
languages, Latin versus Greek.
You now have the western pope
recognizing a different as you could say
Roman emperor in Charlemagne.
The nature of the west
is becoming more Germanic
and using the language Latin,
while the nature of the east
is continuing in Greek traditions.
On top of that what you
have in the year 800,
you're actually in this period
where you've had several conflicts
over this notion of Iconoclasm.
This Iconoclasm movement you could say
started in 726 when the
Byzantine emperor said
enough of these images of
Jesus and the Virgin Mary
and other figures of
Christianity in our churches.
Citing references in the
Old Testament saying that
hey, we shouldn't have these images.
And so, this Iconoclasm or
this destroying of icons
starts to begin.
Well, the pope in the west they say,
"Hey, we don't think we
have to listen to you.
"I am the bishop of Rome.
"I have universal jurisdiction."
And then to add insult
to injury now in 800,
you have Charlemagne being
crowned Holy Roman Emperor.
Now a thread further running through this
is something that we've talked
about in a previous video,
this notion of filioque.
Where in 381 the Council
of Constantinople,
they augment the Nicene
Creed where they say,
"And we believe in the Holy Spirit,
"the Lord and Giver of Life,
"who proceeds from the Father."
While in the west they add
the Latin term filioque
which means and the Son.
And this is touching
on some of these notion
in the Arian Heresy where
where does the Holy Spirit proceed from
if the Father and Son
are really co-divine,
co-equal, of the same substance?
Shouldn't the Holy
Spirit proceed from both
rather than just one?
While those in the east said hey,
this isn't what we agreed to.
While those in the west say
we don't think it's so important
that you agree to things
because we have the seat at Rome,
the seat that was established by Peter.